edward a enneigé en bonsoir bienvenue à
van cats were south
c'est un plaisir de pouvoir vous parler
dans ces circonstances alors que nous
parlons
vanessa et sa fille jeune
fille s'envolent vers leur nouvelle maison une
démocratie libérale un état libre en toute sécurité quels
sont vos  pensées vos sentiments en ce
moment c'est c'est incroyable je je dois
vous dire que j'étais très sceptique que
cela puisse arriver
et Vanessa et sa fille Kiana
se battent depuis si longtemps vous savez
qu'elles sont loin de chez elles je
pense depuis plus  13 ans maintenant, Tiana a
grandi toute sa vie en exil, vous
savez, sans aucune sorte de stabilité,
sans aucune certitude, sans aucune idée de la façon dont
ces choses vont se produire et tout
comme les années ont passé, la vie est devenue de
plus en plus difficile et ils ont fait face de plus
en plus  difficulté du
gouvernement de Hong Kong et c'est vous le savez si
incroyable pour moi qu'ils aient été
punis non seulement pour être simplement des
individus qui veulent vivre normalement en
toute sécurité  heureusement en plein dans leur vie, ils
ont dû partir une fois, mais ensuite ils sont à
Hong Kong et le gouvernement fait
à nouveau pression sur eux simplement parce qu'ils ont aidé
quelqu'un qui dit la vérité
et pour qu'ils aient enfin une
certaine sécurité, vous connaissez un avenir que je peux
Je ne décris pas le sentiment que je suis si reconnaissant et
je suppose que vous avez encore de l'espoir car les
autres étaient encore à Hong Kong maintenant, mais
si nous parlons de Vanessa, parlons
de la terre comme symbole de ce que sont la
porte des anges gardiens, le Snowden
les familles qu'étaient-elles pour vous à un
moment de votre vie en fuite pour être
l'homme le plus recherché de la planète et
puis en juin 2013 vous étiez cet homme que
chaque pays recherchait c'était
c'était une période folle honnêtement euh c'est c'est
drôle à quel point
je me souviens peu de cette période parce que
le stress était si grand, mais l'une des
choses dont je me souviens si clairement est le
sentiment de soulagement que j'ai ressenti lorsque j'ai rencontré
Ajit saponine Atika et Vanessa et leurs
enfants pour le très f  La première fois que vous
savez que je viens de la rue, vous
devez comprendre que vous savez que vous venez de
Hong Kong, vous savez que vous essayez de ne pas être
reconnu. Mon visage est sur les téléviseurs à côté
de chaque immeuble.
Je où vais-
je et ils m'ont ouvert leur porte et
ils n'ont pas demandé qu'ils se moquaient de ce
qui m'arrivait ils savaient ce que c'était
que d'être chassé d'être poursuivi d'être
riposté et ils
m'ont souri toi  sais qu'ils ont ouvert leur maison
et c'était très petit ils vivaient
dans des conditions très difficiles vous savez
une pauvreté incroyable et ils ont partagé
tout ce qu'ils avaient ils ont partagé leur
espoir et leur confiance avec vous ouais
absolument je veux dire ils m'ont donné un avenir
pensez à ce qui aurait pu  m'est arrivé
s'ils n'avaient pas été là, vous avez fait face à une
expulsion hésitante, même
aux États-Unis, vous êtes allé aux Nations
Unies pour vous attribuer le statut de réfugié, mais vous
avez dû trouver un refuge sûr, votre avocat m.
Thibault pensait à eux réfugiés simples
pauvres réfugiés sans avenir c'était un
refuge pour toi ils t'ont sauvé la vie
ils ont pris beaucoup de risques pour toi tu as
mesuré le risque qu'ils ont pris pour toi
à l'époque ben le plus drôle c'est
que  nous avions espéré que vous sachiez qu'il n'y
aurait pas de représailles contre eux
car pourquoi devrait-il y avoir particulièrement en
vertu des lois de Hong Kong je n'avais
commis aucun crime ils n'avaient
commis aucun crime en m'aidant
tout ce qu'ils avaient fait était absolument
légal et au pire vous savez ce que vous
pourriez dire à propos de ces personnes, c'est qu'elles
étaient engagées dans un geste humanitaire
vous savez si nous avions été à Washington DC
cela aurait été une tout autre affaire
mais c'est Hong Kong et pourtant
malgré cela malgré tout faire
bien en
dépit d'être extrêmement prudent pour
s'assurer que nous ne leur faisions aucun mal, cela
n'avait pas d'importance parce que quelque chose que
mon propre avocat m'a dit des années plus tard était
quand vos ennemis ont une sorte de
certain  niveau de force quand vous avez
mis les mauvaises personnes en colère, la
loi n'a pas vraiment d'importance l'affaire
devient 99% de politique et 1
% de loi et pourtant vous savez ce qui
me donne tant d'espoir ce qui me donne tant
d'optimisme est tout d'abord  que ces
gens ont eu un tel courage sur le moment
juste pour faire la bonne chose et ne pas
penser aux conséquences ouais juste
pour penser au niveau humain et puis
juste ici maintenant avec le Canada toutes ces
années plus tard et oui ça a pris beaucoup
trop de temps mais  Le Canada a ouvert ses
portes à une mère et son enfant qui en
avaient désespérément besoin et qui le
méritaient absolument. Je suppose que cela a dû
être une décision difficile pour le Canada.
Nous reviendrons sur ce qui s'est passé
alors, mais il y a une clôture politique.  à
cette décision, ne pensez-vous pas que parce que
vous êtes toujours un ennemi de nombreux États,
vous ne serez pas un réfugié, puis le
Canada dit que vanessa est allée là
-bas et que la fille du propriétaire et peut-être que les
autres ont été la tutrice ang  els à vous,
nous les appelons la famille Snowden et ensuite
ils disent oui, vous êtes les bienvenus au Canada, alors est-
ce une décision difficile pour le Canada
pensez-vous donc j'ai pris la décision
parce qu'ils font face à la menace d'expulsion
oui la torture s'ils étaient expulsés vers
elle en  Philippine mais les autres au Sri
Lanka ouais non ce sont
absolument les bonnes questions à poser
mais je pense que cela arrive à la mauvaise
conclusion et c'est en fait la
décision la plus facile au monde
à prendre pour le Canada parce que ces gens ont le
meilleur cas de  n'importe quel type de demandeur d'asile,
vous pouvez imaginer qu'ils n'ont fait aucun mal,
ils n'ont fait que du bien, vous dites bien sûr
qu'il y a des pays qui me considèrent comme
une sorte de problème, mais même dans mon propre
pays,
les États-Unis, nous ne sommes pas
plus longtemps en 2013 où Barack Obama était tellement
inquiet de sa réputation d'avoir été
surpris en train d'enfreindre la loi et c'est de
cela qu'il s'agissait en 2013, il s'agissait d'un
acte répréhensible révélateur d'
activités anticonstitutionnelles violations de la plate-forme humaine  hts par
le gouvernement des États-Unis non seulement
contre les Américains, même si cela
s'est absolument produit, mais les gens
du monde entier, aux États-Unis, n'ont
pas réussi à respecter leurs
idéaux maintenant, alors que nous passons à l'
avenir, le procureur général Eric Holder
qui avait initialement  vous savez m'a accusé
de crimes juste après avoir quitté son
poste, il a dit qu'il croyait maintenant avoir
quitté son bureau que ce que j'ai fait était un
service public et le monde à travers les
frontières à travers les juridictions, ils
sont désormais d'accord même avec les directeurs de
la NSA qui enquêtaient sur moi
a dit que c'était des choses que le
gouvernement des États-Unis aurait dû admettre bien
avant que je ne me présente et donc quand je
regarde la décision que le Canada a dû prendre
alors que la sagesse conventionnelle serait
oui, ce serait difficile parce
qu'il y avait des réputations et il y avait des
gens qui étaient  gêné par le
passage du temps avec le genre de
justification des changements dans la loi et de
tout ce qui a ha  ppappendi ici que ce que le
Canada fait réellement est d'aider les
États-Unis à respecter leurs propres idéaux
en protégeant les personnes qui le méritent, alors
revenons un instant à Hong Kong.
Je devais vous identifier dans les bidonvilles de
Hong Kong avec d'autres réfugiés  et je
suppose que c'était l'endroit le plus sûr parce que
vous penseriez que les autorités
s'occuperaient de vous dans ces bidonvilles après avoir
quitté un hôtel cinq étoiles en tant que
prisonnier ouais vous savez que c'est
quelque chose que je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous
qui sont nés et  élevé dans les
démocraties développées, perdre de vue comment
vit la majorité de la population mondiale et pour moi en tant que technologue, en
particulier quelqu'un qui a travaillé dans la
communauté du renseignement qui a travaillé dans la
surveillance, une si grande partie de nos vies est
médiatisée par la technologie, je suis juste
dans  deux écrans je regarde
la vie des autres mais je ne les
touche pas vraiment je ne les
comprends pas vraiment c'était un moment
où j'étais vous savez perdu et désespéré
et ils s'ouvrent  a ouvert la porte et c'était une
porte vers un monde différent et c'était un
monde où les gens n'avaient rien de
bien, il y avait très
peu de biens matériels
qu'ils avaient les uns les autres et à cause de cela la
vie était en fait plus réelle  et je pense
d'une certaine manière plus plus
épanouissant et j'ai
énormément d'admiration et de respect pour
eux et honnêtement les choses que j'ai
apprises ont changé votre vie à bien des
égards juste ces 15 jours avec ces
réfugiés quand nous avons interviewé Lenny Sol la
dernière fois  tomber, elle nous a dit Edward Snowden
est là ero pour nous, elle nous l'a dit
et si un jour je peux l'aider,
je l'aiderai comment peut-elle lq je pense
que la meilleure façon est qu'elle puisse m'aider
aujourd'hui, elle peut aider tous  nous est juste d'
être la meilleure mère pour Kiana alors
qu'elle peut et de se souvenir de tout ce
que nous avons tous traversé elle en a
assez fait pour moi tu sais elle m'appelle
un héros elle est mon héros mm-hmm combien
les jeunes sont reconnaissants envers Vanessa  et les autres pas
moi je  Je veux dire que c'est le genre de chose que tu
ne peux pas mettre plus comme tu sais de un
à dix à quel point es-tu reconnaissant pour
quelque chose qui change vraiment la
direction de ta vie quand je
pense juste au fondamental je
n'ai pas de décent  non désolé je n'ai pas d'
enfants à moi mais quand je pense
à ce que c'était de voir
ces petites filles et leurs
parents tu sais juste lutter pour s'en
sortir et se tailler une sorte de vie et
une sorte d'avenir et certains  une sorte d'
espoir s'il y avait quelque chose que je pouvais faire pour
aider à cela après tout ce qu'ils avaient fait
pour m'aider, je le ferais et c'est pourquoi
ces dernières années, j'ai travaillé
avec les réfugiés et le groupe
d'avocats canadiens et surtout
Robert  Thibault qui a vraiment en quelque sorte
abandonné sa vie professionnellement, il a
été absolument chassé de Hong Kong
pour s'assurer que nous obtenons un meilleur résultat pour
ces familles et le fait que Vanessa
et Keanu entrent enfin pour la première fois au
Canada, vous savez  Je
ne peux pas, je ne peux pas exprimer à quel point je leur suis reconnaissant
à tous
maintenant que Vanessa est un rêve devenu
réalité pour elle, elle prévoit un avenir avec
son enfant, comment cela affecte-t-il vos propres
rêves ou j'espère que vous m'avez toujours
critiqué  depuis 2013 pour avoir dit que
je suis trop naïf, je suis trop optimiste,
vous savez ce que je pensais qu'il se passerait vraiment
si je disais aux gens qu'il y avait des
droits violés par le
gouvernement, vous savez que le gouvernement
nous espionnait tous sur tout  d'entre nous n'avait pas
vraiment d'importance ce que la loi disait
c'est ce qu'ils vont faire c'est comme ça que
ça va toujours être les choses ne vont jamais
s'améliorer c'est comme ça que la vie
est et ils ont dit la même chose à propos
des familles qu'ils ont dit  personne ne s'en
soucie comme s'ils allaient être renvoyés
Hong Kong ne fera rien à ce
sujet comme s'il n'y aurait pas de
fin heureuse à cela, mais voyez ces choses
ne sont vraies que si nous les laissons se
produire comme vous appelez naïf ou ce que certaines personnes
appeler naïf est actu  Allié, juste
espérer que les choses peuvent changer, c'est un
engagement à essayer d'améliorer un
peu les choses et bien sûr, vous savez
qu'aucun de nous ne peut sauver le monde, vous savez
par nous-mêmes, nous n'avons pas de baguette magique, les
choses ne sont pas ça  simple mais nous n'avons pas
à sauver le monde entier en une seule fois
tout ce que nous avons à faire est de faire ce
petit pas et c'est ce que c'est ce n'est
pas assez bien nous avons encore un
diacre saponine et Ajit qui sont encore très
bien  en danger avec leurs enfants
mais c'est un pas en avant et c'est un
début et si nous faisons un autre pas
et nous faisons un autre pas la vie peut
s'améliorer l'avenir peut être meilleur tout ce que nous
avons à faire est de continuer à essayer d'accord je
comprends en entendant  toi tu es toujours
tu seras toujours
pour eux et tu plaideras pour leur cas jusqu'à
ce que tout soit complètement résolu et que les
autres soient aussi au Canada si tu avais le
premier ministre Trudeau devant toi
maintenant que lui dirais-tu je dirais d'
abord  merci de ne pas
intervenir  et empêcher ce cas
de se présenter en premier lieu,
mais veuillez également reconnaître ce que cela fait
aux familles qui ont été séparées
et si vous comprenez que cela peut être fait
dans un cas, vous comprenez que ces
personnes méritent absolument une
protection et que c'est  pas une
action hostile, c'est l'acte d'un
ami, les États-Unis ont
trébuché de manière réelle et n'importe qui peut
regarder la situation dans laquelle se trouvent les États-
Unis en ce moment et se rendre compte qu'elle est
troublée et pour la relation
entre les États-Unis et le Canada
qui  a été si important pendant si longtemps que
nous avons besoin que le Canada nous aide à vivre
nos idéaux et nous en avons besoin maintenant
et c'est un exemple c'est une
circonstance où canikin Canada peut faire
quelque chose de bien non seulement pour ces
familles mais pour les États-Unis  États et
pour tous ceux dans le monde qui croient
aux droits de l'homme, l'idée que nous avons le
droit d'être protégés contre ce type de
persécution en fuyant la torture
et la sexualité  al violence et tous les
troubles et persécutions auxquels ces
familles ont été confrontées pendant des années et
j'espère qu'ils veilleront à
ce que cette affaire soit correctement résolue. Eh
bien, Edward Snowden, merci beaucoup,
mais vous n'avez pas vraiment répondu à ma question à
propos de  tes rêves quels sont tes espoirs les plus
importants pour toi si je me trouve à
la fin de tout cela je te demande honnêtement
je suis complètement satisfait je ne peux rien demander
mais si je pouvais te voir connais un
espoir dans le futur c'est tu sais  comme les
choses ont évolué à mesure que nous sommes sortis
de ce point difficile de l'histoire, c'est
que je pourrai un jour remercier Nessa et
Kiana en personne et le faire au
Canada c'est le dernier mot merci
beaucoup mr.  snow
nous allons vous suivre sur twitter car
vous très souvent vous demandez une reconnaissance
pour eux et espérez pour eux et aussi pour
les réfugiés sur cette organisation et
aussi vous défendez la liberté de la presse
merci beaucoup mr.  Snowden d'avoir
pris le temps merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir couvert cette affaire et
merci à tous ceux au Canada et dans le
monde qui se sont portés volontaires qui ont fait un don
et qui ont essayé de s'assurer que
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui s'est produit c'est
tout grâce à  merci beaucoup merci